يبدو أن وكالة المخابرات المركزية الأمريكية يبدو أن ما يبدو حقًا
أن وكالة المخابرات المركزية تؤمن به بشكل
مختلف وسمعت
الأشرطة وجعلتها تعتبر تقييمًا
لأن وكالة المخابرات ستفعل ذلك ،
ويبدو أن الكونجرس لا يزال لديه شكوك
حول التستر
والإنكار بشأن  الأمير محمد بن سلمان ،
أليس من الأفضل إذا فعلت ذلك
إذا أنكرت الحكومة أنه
ولي العهد أخبرنا من كان
وكيف تعرف أنه لم يكن ولي العهد ،
لا ينبغي للحكومة أن تخبرنا بذلك
حسنًا ، أعني أن ننظر إلى شيئين أولاً وقبل كل شيء
، خرجت وكالة المخابرات المركزية بتسريب
، ولم يكن هناك بيان من وكالة المخابرات المركزية ،
فقد خرج من خلال تسريب مثل
تسريب واشنطن مثل الغربال ،
وقالت إنه استنادًا إلى أن وكالة المخابرات المركزية ليس لديها
دليل مباشر ولكنها كانت تستند إلى
فهمهم لكيفية حدوث الأشياء في
المملكة العربية السعودية مع كل الاحترام الواجب
لوكالة المخابرات المركزية ، أعتقد أنه ربما يكون
فهمهم لما يحدث في
الأماكن المقدسة الداخلية للقصر الملكي غير
كامل ومن ثم يكون لديك  أعرف أن
الوزير ماتيس والوزير بومبيو
يخرجان أمس ويقولان بصراحة
إنهما قد راجعا كل وثيقة
تتعلق بهذا ، وقراءة كل نص
، وببساطة
لا يوجد دليل على أن ولي العهد فعل
ذلك ، في مواجهة ذلك ليس
فقط  البيت الأبيض ليس الرئيس فقط ،
لكنهم قالوا إن
المؤسستين ، البنتاغون ووزارة الخارجية ،
قد نظرتا في كل شيء ،
وقد خرجوا وقالوا ببساطة
إنه لا يوجد سلاح قوي ، نعم لا أحد
يريد تصديق ذلك